en el extremo sur de Luisiana en este
bayú el francés se habla a diario
salsa y Cristina son indígenas de pantus
una tribu descendiente de los primeros
habitantes de América que aprendió el
francés de los colonos en el siglo XVIII
en su infancia el francés era la única
lengua
si no hablabas francés no podías hablar
con tu madre o tu abuelo y uno hablaba
nada de inglés mi abuela se llamaba
antoinette
y nuestros bisabuelos se llamaban
placidietmond la lengua francesa forma
parte de su identidad pero es difícil de
defender en un mundo anglófono por eso
saber que el presidente francés viene a
Luisiana es especialmente conmovedor
estoy muy contento de que venga y de que
vea que todavía tenemos esta conexión
con Francia aquí abajo
Christine se reunirá con Emanuel mccon
este viernes junto a una docena de
miembros de la comunidad francofona
entre ellos wilmargueo fundador de tele
Luisiana el primer medio de comunicación
totalmente francófono del estado
estamos en la mejor posición para contar
nuestra historia y es fundamental contar
esas historias en la lengua que hasta
hace poco era la dominante en el estado
el francés de Luisiana
Will Encarna a la nueva generación de
luisianos que luchan por mantener vivo
el francés Emmanuel es el tercer
presidente de la república que visita a
Luisiana tras el general dugol y vale
está una visita cargada de simbolismo En
este estado que antaño formaba parte de
Nueva Francia